Let's go next to our caller from the four
zero one area code.
Who's calling today from four zero one,
Hey, Dave, it's, it's scary.
Hey Dave, what's up?
Um, uh, I, I understand that the electoral
colleges, uh, they had to stop certain faction
or demographic, whatever from ruling indefinitely,
but it seems as though it's working against
this purpose.
My question is, do you think the electoral
college will ever be done away with what would
the process be and how come?
There seems to be plenty of talk about it
and no action.
I'm from Rhode Island, which by the way,
I was going to say, is that a Rhode Island
for Hillary?
I, uh, I voted for Bernie
[inaudible].
Listen, so you're completely right.
The electoral college.
And one of the main priorities of it was we
don't want all of the rural areas being ignored
and having candidates mass at cities and only
paying attention to them.
But what we have in practice is that the candidates
are just paying attention to these key early
States and States that are strategically significant.
It's still ignoring a whole bunch of different
people.
And quite frankly, with modern media, I don't
really care where the candidate goes.
I don't care if, if a candidate comes to Boston
or not, they're better than Donald Trump,
I'm going to vote for them.
Right?
So I think that you're, you're right in your
analysis, the bet, the most or the simplest
path to removing the electoral college is
the national popular vote interstate compact.
You can basically just do it at the state
level if you get enough States whose electoral
votes total two 72 decide we award our electoral
votes not to the winter and our state, but
to the winner of the national popular vote,
you effectively create a national popular
vote, doesn't require ratification by, uh,
by, by States, doesn't require a vote in the
house and Senate.
That for me is the most direct path to it,
right?
So then basically that has to be like within
the 50 States, like a statewide coalition
or something to, uh, to go to the governor
and say, well, we want the popular vote, not
the electoral vote.
This is bull.
Then you basically say, and some States, some
States have done it, Dave and the state would
say, okay, so normally the way a state awards
electoral votes is if a candidate wins.
Massachusetts, Massachusetts gives their electorial
votes to that candidate.
Massachusetts can decide, we'll vote, but
we aren't going to give the votes, the electoral
votes to the winner of our state.
We're going to give the votes to the winner
of the popular vote nationally.
They get their data gets room, we'll choose
that or whatever act that, um, like America.
So, so you have to let get the valve owner
or whoever's in charge of that secretary of
state, um, um, to like go to them with a,
almost kinda like a, um, petition.
It can be done via a ballot initiative at
the state in a state election ballot initiative.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, I'll doubt I'd asked you and a side
question, like, how come there isn't there
like States like, uh, you know, North Dakota
or something was the no zero population has,
uh, more or less all votes then like a more
populated smallest state.
Like why is that still a thing?
Yeah.
So it is that smaller state because of how
the, the electoral votes are apportioned.
Smaller States don't have more votes, but
they have disproportionately more relative
to their populations.
That is true.
And that's another one of the problems with
our system.
Seems like the deck is stacked is
yes, absolutely.
Absolutely.
Dave from Rhode Island.
Thank you so much for the call.
I appreciate the call.